bonjour à tous c'est une année un peu
particulière pour les journées du
patrimoine puisqu'avec la situation
sanitaire vous êtes assez peu nombreux à
pouvoir visiter l'assemblée n'est cp
pense à vous puisque dans le reportage
qui va suivre
vous allez pouvoir découvrir une
tapisserie hors du commun qui va sans
doute attirer tous les regards
il s'agit de l'école d'athènes elle a
passé trois ans entre les mains du
mobilier national qui lui a offert une
seconde jeunesse
et elle fait donc son grand retour dans
l'hémicycle maïté frémont nous livre les
détails de cette restauration délicate
la séance est ouverte
vous avez sans doute assister à des
après midi entiers de questions au
gouvernement encore faut-il que vous
soyez à l'écouté que la majorité cessent
de nous humilier regarder des heures et
des heures de débat dans l'hémicycle
sans jamais vraiment la remarque
[Musique]
cinq mètres de haut
neuf mètres de large voici l'immense
tapisserie qui depuis 141 ans trône au
dessus du fameux perchoir l'école
d'athènes
à force d'être là elle passait inaperçu
sa restauration l'a fait revenir en
pleine lumière
ce 15 septembre 2020 la séance de
rentrée parlementaire est un peu spécial
madame et monsieur lévy sur les bancs
des ministres pas de gouvernement sur le
directeur du mobilier national
ceux qui ont restauré la toile sont tous
là je veux remercier et féliciter la
manufacture des gobelins qui s'est
acquitté avec un remarquable
savoir-faire de cette tâche
et pour célébrer le grand retour du
chef-d'oeuvre et richard ferrand ce
livre un petit cours d'histoire à
l'origine derrière le fauteuil
présidentiel
c'était un grand tableau à la gloire de
louis philippe convoyait montrant le roi
des français
une scène qui déplaît quand le 24
février 1848 le peuple de paris s'invite
dans l'hémicycle pour y demander la
république alors louis-philippe enlevés
il fallut trouver une oeuvre qui
convienne à tous et ce fut l'école
d'athènes l'école d'athènes
une tapisserie tissée au xviie siècle à
la demande de louis xiv copie d'une
fresque du vatican 58 philosophe et
scientifique de platon et aristote
d'archimède à pythagore sont disposés
sur les marges d'une bibliothèque par la
grâce du génie de raphaël
un chef-d'oeuvre témoin depuis 1879 des
échos de l'histoire la tapisserie a
traversé trois républiques connu deux
guerres le drapeau nazi
elle a vu l'avènement de la vème
république assisté à la bataille pour
l'avortement
je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire
partager une conviction de femmes
je m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes elle a aussi vécu l'abolition
de la peine de mort
la pollution de la peine de mort et le
mariage pour tous de quoi sortir de
l'hémicycle
un peu usés
[Musique]
pendant des décennies dans cette
assemblée où là on a fumé le cigare
abondamment probablement évidemment la
tapisserie avait fini par un peu
s'encrasser les fils de la chaîne donc
l'architecte une nouvelle fois de la
tapisserie c'était un peu distendues
donc il convenait de la deûle à nettoyer
de la restaurer de permettre de
rafraîchir un peu ses couleurs et
surtout de la renforcer de façon à ce
qu'elle puisse de nouveau être
réinstallés dans l'assemblée nationale
en 2017 la tapisserie quittent
l'hémicycle pour la manufacture des
gobelins
là où elle est née quatre siècles plus
tôt pendant 1700 jours dans cet atelier
5 restauratrice vont lui rendre sa
jeunesse et ses couleurs
les yeux rivés sur l'oeuvre elles vont
retisser fils après phil les visages les
toges les décors abîmée par le temps
bénédicte a fait partie de l'équipe de
choc avec sa collègue
c'est désormais sur une autre tapisserie
quel travail
les motifs sont différents mais le geste
lui est le même cette usure ressemble à
celle qu'on a pu rencontrer sa
tapisserie ou donc là on voit que c'est
une partie donc abîmé la les chaînes
sont à nu casser la trame est manquante
donc il n'ya plus de dessin il n'y a
plus de deux tapisseries en fait on ne
recherche pas à redessiner houard
combler les parties manquantes mais
simplement à à maintenir l'existant les
milliers d'heures passées sur l'oeuvre
sont consignés dans un classeur à chaque
photo un outrage du temps à réparer n'a
eu un trou où on pouvait passer la main
en fait dedans
les restauratrices n'en sont pas à leur
premier chef-d'oeuvre mais celui ci les
a marqués sur cette pâtisserie là on
s'est quand même un petit peu at a fait
elle est exposée disons à l'assemblée
nationale dans l'hémicycle mais on a
quand même marrant c'est quand même
approprié pendant deux ans et demi parce
qu'il ya eu des épreuves même avec le
confinement ça a été compliqué et donc
il a fallu mettre les bouchées doubles
pour finir à temps une députée est venu
à la manufacture des gobelins en octobre
dernier céline calvaise membre de la
commission des affaires culturelles a
voulu voir de près ce travail titanesque
bayar a démarré bien s'intégrer
ce qui lui tenait à coeur c'était de
mettre en avant ces artistes de l'ombre
on ne les voit pas d'habitude et donc
moi le fait de pouvoir remettre sur
twitter ce qui avait été ma découverte
et leur rencontre au mois d'octobre
était aussi une manière de montrer non
pas seulement leurs visages mais aussi
leurs techniques de montrer la précision
avec laquelle elles elles font ce
travail de restauration elles sont peu
mais elles sont indispensables
et alors potentiellement ce qui est
intéressant à souligner c'est qu'il ya
un paradoxe sur sept écoles d'athènes de
rafael vous n'avez que des hommes des
hommes qui représentent des savants qui
représente des philosophes de l'air
grecque antique est par contre sont les
femmes qui font que ces hommes peuvent
encore apparaître sur cette toile
aujourd'hui on est 40 % de femmes à
pouvoir être à siéger ici
bon bah non non pas encore les oeuvres
d'art qui sont datés de notre période
que des hommes pour symboliser
l'intelligence de l'esprit le génie
dominique cordeliers conservateur au
musée du louvre
il a étudié comment raphaël avait
réparti sur sa fresque toutes les formes
du savoir en gros il y a trois grands
groupes au centre donc platon aristote
les percuter l'ère de la philosophie en
bas à gauche
pythagore qui l'homme de l'homme
dénombre l'homme
l'homme d'une pensée théorique basé sur
les nombres et puis à droite
euclide qui est lui plutôt le
représentant d'une pensée pratique
empirique à partir des mêmes données
ces penseurs de l'antiquité raphaël re a
parfois donné les traits de ses
contemporains platon a pris le visage de
léonard de vinci
héraclite est représenté sous les traits
de michel-ange raphaël n'hésite pas à
rendre hommage à ses rivaux rafael a mis
tout son talent tout son génie à avoir
l'intelligence la plus généreuse des de
tout ce qu'ils pouvaient voir autour de
lui quand il voit l'oeuvre de léonard de
vinci il se dit c'est formidable se
récupère ce qu'elle meilleurs quand ils
voient michel-ange il se dit c'est
formidable il faut que vous vous j'en
prenne ce qu'il ya de meilleur
il est le seul des trois à avoir cette
cette finesse là qui est de dire on peut
dépasser la dimension conflictuelle des
on peut dire des rivalités artistiques
parce qu'on peut avoir l'intelligence
stylistiques des deux de ses pairs et ça
c'est le coup de génie de rappel
dépasser les conflits pour privilégier
le beau ou la vérité une des nombreuses
leçons à retenir dans l'oeuvre de
raphaël
elle rassemble tout ce que la
philosophie antique a produit de plus
grand et de plus inspirant la morale la
science les arts la sagesse qui parfois
manque dans cet hémicycle annie genevard
est une ancienne historienne de l'art
la députée du doubs fait partie des
parlementaires amoureux de cette
tapisserie
de son siège de député à droite dans
l'hémicycle sa vue sur l'oeuvre est
imprenable
elles sont nées d'ailleurs servi une
fois pour porter la réplique à un
ministre monsieur le président c'était
dans 2013 et elle s'en souvient encore
nous examinions le texte sur la
refondation de l'école et c'est le
ministre vincent peillon quitte alors en
responsabilité et c'était un soir si je
me souviens bien il avait dès début
d'examen de texte qui était un peu
difficile d' assez agressif et il avait
méchamment ironisé sur le manque de
culture d'un député et j'avais été outré
par le procédé
soyez comptable de vos propos vous le
serez de doller monsieur hessel votre
intervention n'a pas été la plus
brillante de celles de vos collègues il
a été exclusivement polémique comme
d'habitude mais vous êtes blessé je le
comprends mais vous le méritez
croyez moi madame genevard et c'est là
que la tapisserie intervient si mme la
présidente
je ne vous ferai pas l'injure monsieur
le ministre de vous demander ce que
représente cette tapisserie je suis sûr
que vous le savez en philosophe que vous
êtes
permettez-moi de l'expliquer à tous les
ignorants de cette assemblée qui
évidemment qui évidemment sont plus
nombreux sur nos bancs que sur les
vôtres alors puisque platon et
représenter permettez moi monsieur le
ministre de citer un philosophe qui vous
est cher sans doute puisqu'il s'agit de
l'auteur du gorgias qui dit ceci la
plupart des hommes mais ça n'est pas
votre cas ni le nôtre la plupart des
hommes au pouvoir deviennent des
méchants et j'y ajouterai j ajouterai
pythagore j ajouterai pythagore soit
juste dans ses gestes soient justes dans
tes gestes et des paroles suit les
préceptes de la raison et de la loi je
vous remets
pythagore à une autre adepte un peu plus
à gauche dans l'hémicycle
valérie rabault ancien rapporteur du
budget est une férue de mathématiques et
de sciences pour la députée il s'agit en
quelque sorte pour elle et ses collègues
d'être à la hauteur de cette tapisserie
c'est pas anodin d'avoir choisi l'école
d'athènes c'est à dire c'est démontrer
que le savoir toutes les sciences les
sciences humaines la physique les
mathématiques est clair la décision du
législateur la démocratie athénienne
nous parle toujours nous en sommes les
héritiers
enfin petit passage et que donc on a une
forme aussi une responsabilité enfin
c'est une inscription à la fois dans
l'histoire à la fois par rapport au
monde des idées et surtout surtout c'est
l'idée que la raison est toujours très
importante dans un débat démocratique
la raison pour guider les débats sous
l'oeil des 58 sages dont raphaël
lemaître s'était peint dans un coin de
la toile mais il était caché par le
cadre la restauration a permis de le
redécouvrir
ils sont donc désormais tous bien
présent à surveiller de là haut
les travaux des députés
[Musique]